واياكم هذه الصور التي وصلتنا من ارسال
الجيش السوداني تعزيزات للخرطوم هذا
واشارت هنا مصادر الى ان القوات هذه التي
نتابعها بهذه الصور جاءت من ولايتي من
ولايتي النيل الازرق والجزيره ومدينه
عطبره في ولايه نهر النيل اذا تعزيزات
جديده للجيش السوداني الى الخرطوم
[موسيقى]
اذا الطابور طويل من التعزيزات العسكريه
للجيش السوداني من جنوب الخرطوم الى داخل
الخرطوم طبعا هذا ينظر
اشتداء تحدث المعارك والاشتباكات بالساعات
المقبله بعد انتهاء الهدنه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات